Speaker 1: . I got a really interesting voicemail
that I want to play for you. Of course, you can
call the voicemail number any time of day. The
number is two one nine two. David P. Here is a
voicemail about why do people who are anti Semitic
claim to love Israel? It doesn't make sense.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, I was just wondering if you
had any insights into why these people that hate
Jews so much are so pro-Israel. I don't get it.
Speaker 1: Thank you. There's a couple different
things going on. Number one, a lot
of the evangelical support for Israel
is not rooted in any desire to provide a safe
haven for Jews that have been persecuted and,
you know, dozens and dozens of countries for
a thousand years or longer. It's not rooted in
that for many evangelicals. It's rooted in we
believe the second coming of Jesus will happen
when there is a strong Israel and then there's a
bunch a bunch of different versions of it when a
temple is rebuilt or whatever. OK, but basically
they believe that the second coming of Jesus will
happen if they support Israel. Others believe
the rapture will happen if they support Israel.
For some, it's one in the same. There's all these
different sects and they tend to have different
beliefs. So that's part of it. And then for many
others on the right, it's either just they sort
of like militarism and they like the idea of
there's other countries that have some of the
cool advanced weapons that we have and or they see
it as a way to sort of fight proxy wars against
populations they don't like in the Middle East.
But it's not it's I understand that it sounds like
a lot of these people are anti Semitic. They
often play into anti Semitic tropes, repeat them,
etc. But they claim to support Israel. They are
two completely different things and much the same
as what is going on with American anti-Semitism
is a separate issue from Israeli foreign policy.
The anti Semites who claim to like Israel, are
sort of operating in two different spaces. And
it might sound like it's one incoherent space
and to some degree it is. But for many of them,
these are completely different issues. There's the
political state of Israel and then there's Jews
about whom they have a prejudiced beliefs in
the United States and sort of the day to day
community. It's a very good question because it
does seem incoherent and inconsistent. And in
a sense, it absolutely is. We have a great
bonus show for you today. I'm out of time,
but trust me, it's a good one. Sign up at David
Pakman dot com and you'll get instant access.